nós mulheres estamos cansadas e há tanto
tempo que já estamos cansados de estar
cansado mas desde sempre a mídia retrata
gente de uma forma muito precária
somos o corpo objetificado uma opinião
deslegitimada conquistas minimizadas
nossas com nossos valores não estão
refletidos ali na mídia
nossa nosso valor e ele está sempre
atrelado ao olhar do outro é sempre o
que ele diz é sempre que os homens olham
e dizem sobre a gente que vale mas nos
últimos tempos a gente conquistou tanta
coisa nós mulheres saímos de casa e
vamos trabalhar
hoje somos maioria nós estamos presentes
no mercado de trabalho são os
responsáveis por quase 40% dos lares
brasileiros financeiramente
vamos estudar e somos 55% dos alunos nas
escolas universidades
somos 43% dos empreendedores
somos líderes executivas somos
realizadoras mas não é isso que a mídia
diz sobre nós pra ela continuamos sendo
um pedaço de carne que carrega cerveja
pra lá e pra cá um cabide de roupas e
sapatos
uma dona de casa que perde o sono por
conta de uma mancha na camisa do marido
ea para as mulheres negras é ainda pior
elas não conseguem se reconhecer que ela
sequer estão ali
cansadas e com a internet impõe nós
vamos à luta
derrubamos campanhas questionamos marcas
criticamos governos usamos a ferida e
muita gente foi obrigado a se repensar
quem produz quem vende e quem compra e
quem faz a comunicação é importante
pensar que hoje a gente vive um momento
de expansão de consciência em que cada
um precisa fazer sua parte para melhorar
o todo e quem não assume essa
responsabilidade é alvo de duras
críticas à comunicação é a mesma coisa
os estereótipos antigos já não fazem
mais efeito
o politicamente incorreto
perdeu a graça está fora de moda
tá na hora da publicidade assume que ela
é parte da cultura não apenas um reflexo
dela foi justamente para mudar essa
cultura que surgiu a eva que é um núcleo
de inteligência do feminino que se
dedica conectar marcas a mulheres mas as
mulheres reais não as mulheres dos
estereótipos a nossa história começará
em 2013 quando a gente fundou a fim que
olga que hoje é uma ong que se dedica ao
empoderamento feminino por meio da
informação
nosso trabalho é trazer assuntos
importantes e temas que são caros das
mulheres como assédio sexual a violência
o empoderamento como um todo só que a
gente busca trazer isso de forma leve e
palatável ou seja acessível e nesse
tempo a gente conseguiu um relativo
sucesso impactamos milhares de mulheres
milhares de pessoas mas principalmente a
nós mesmas
é nessa época né de 2003 até
recentemente eu trabalhava com
publicidade numa consultoria de
planejamento viver de perto a realidade
dos clientes
eu via como o machismo estava impregnado
no comportamento engolir seco cada
provocação na sala de reunião
eu sabia que aquilo precisava mudar um
dia um cliente disse pra mim mas não
sabe quando vocês mulheres não estão se
sentindo muito bem então se coloca uma
roupa decotada e vão pra frente da obra
pra ver se recebe um elogio e assim se
sentem melhor e levantou a autoestima e
eu falei não não sei
e pensei comigo não só eu não sei como
eu estou muito ofendido com essa sua
visão romantizada sobre um problema
sério que atinge todas as mulheres que é
o assédio sexual locais públicos
a partir desse dia tive certeza que o
mercado precisava de da gente estava na
hora de levar o empoderamento feminino
não pra só para as mulheres mas pra
dentro das instituições marcas empresas
e governos
então eu e minha sócia juliana de faria
e na lima
armamos nosso plano de dominação mundial
a gente queria fazer uma revolução que
fosse de fora pra dentro com a alga e
trazendo as mulheres pra dentro da
discussão e mostrando o poder que elas
têm mas também de fora pra dentro
a gente queria lhe trazer às empresas e
governos para dentro desse movimento e
assim conseguirmos as mudanças mais mais
rápido de forma mais efetiva
bom o mercado sabia que a gente sabia
que precisava do mercado mas o mercado
não sabe ainda que precisava da gente
então a gente decidiu colocar nossa
nosso conhecimento em números
lançamos uma pesquisa para entender como
as mulheres estavam se relacionando com
a publicidade
entrevistamos mais de mil mulheres de
todas as classes sociais em todos os
lugares do brasil e que a gente teve foi
um retrato em números na época e números
não lembre que pudessem ajudar a gente
na argumentação com os clientes
os resultados são tristes mas não são
esperadas para a maioria das mulheres a
publicidade hoje desperta a mesmice
esse foi o sentimento mais citado e
depois a mesmice
a rejeição à opressão ea frustração com
né
pensa que a gente as marcas estão
colocando um monte de dinheiro fazendo
comunicação e é isso que elas estão
despertando nas mulheres bem a gente
sabia é que esse problema era grande e
agora a gente tinha ele inúmeros mas a
gente queria também apresentar soluções
não só o problema
então a gente perguntou para as mulheres
o que elas gostariam de ver retratado
além do é quais eram os atributos que a
mídia não está trabalhando hoje que elas
gostariam de ver refletidos ali para 85
ponto 9% delas a inteligência de ser
retratadas como mulheres inteligentes é
um desejo como seres capazes de fazer
escolhas para quase 70% para mulheres e
pela independência 72% para atitude
quase 65 e para a força seja força
física literal ou a força de vontade ea
força de realização para quase 60 por
cento
a gente entende que isso são caminhos
que estão dentro do universo do
empoderamento feminino mulheres assim
retratadas se sentem automaticamente
mais poderosas o zakat uso arquétipos
estereótipos podem se transformar e
entrar na luta junto com a gente e não
contra
recentemente muitas marcas entenderam
essa necessidade ea gente foi inclusive
pesquisar cases tinham coisas
acontecendo fora do brasil ea gente
queria saber como que isso se refletirá
dentro das marcas também uma forma de
argumentação para mostrar para o mercado
e somos relevantes vocês precisam mesmo
da gente ea gente viu a há alguns anos a
um cenário que mostrava que o
empoderamento ele não é só bom para as
mulheres e é bom para o negócio também
uma marca por exemplo de lingerie
americana ao tirar o photoshop de suas
campanhas e trazer mulheres reais
aumentou suas vendas em 40%
uma outra de xampus aumentou 8% seu
market share
ao debater os os vieses inconsciência
por que as mulheres são vistas de um
jeito e os homens de outro pela mesma
atitude e uma terceira se transformou
lida no dl de recall no mercado
na top of mind por é falar sobre qual é
o preconceito existente dentro da
expressão fazer coisas como uma menina
estava aprovado então era bom para o
negócio traria resultados levanta a traz
uma percepção de inovação de
diferenciação é um ótimo caminho para as
marcas e claro elas não são bobas elas
logo entenderam isso
o ano passado foi um ano muito
importante para o empoderamento feminino
muitas conquistas aconteceram e esse
assunto se transformou num tema
conversado pelas pessoas pelas famílias
em todos os lugares
claro as marcas começaram então a pular
para dentro a gente queria que elas
usassem o empoderamento a favor delas
mas claro sempre trazendo um retorno
para a sociedade
a gente viu muita gente falando sobre é
empoderamento de uma forma vazia
então ali de rosa e dizem olha que
estamos falando em poderão as mulheres
mas dentro das empresas continuam
pagando os salários diferentes continuam
demitindo mulheres após a
licença-maternidade continuam praticando
atos e já cede moral e sexual e não
represento não reprimindo esse tipo de
comportamento
a eva ela se dedica ao empoderamento de
verdade
o nosso objetivo é com que é fazer com
que a transformação que a gente acredita
que seja necessária na sociedade
aconteça de fato nós somos guardiães
desse tema e nós estamos aqui para levar
marcas e pessoas juntas através da
consulta de uma consultoria de branding
em estratégia ou de conteúdos inovadores
ou de ações de educação e palestras
então quando alguém pergunta qual é o
segredo de falar com as mulheres
entender que mulheres são pessoas são
seres capazes que fazem escolhas que
pensam que são complexas têm defeitos e
qualidades como qualquer outra pessoa e
que por isso merecem ser honrados
merecem ser celebramos o empoderamento
chegou de verdade e ele veio pra ficar
ele não é um caminho sem volta
o tempo é de transformação vocês estão
preparados